on the hill tonight for the indians is
jean carlos mejia
6'5 240 pounds 24 years of age and mejia
trying to figure out a way to stay out
of the beginning if he can stay out of
the big inning well he can be a very
good pitcher the pitch swing
and a foul tip into the glove of austin
hedges strike three
g-man choi batting 250 five homers 24
rbis
this one in the air to left
drifting back to the track to the wall
and it's gone
ramirez watches it go
and g-man choi with just six homers on
the season has a round tripper and
back-to-back nights
brandon you must mention his struggles
against lefty this is a sinker
dead down the middle g-man troy gets
extended on it just keeps carrying and
carrying out and one thing we didn't
mention about me is it struggles in the
first inning and the rays take a
one-nothing first-inning lead drew
rasmussen will get the start for tampa
he already has a one-nothing lead as we
head to the bottom of the first this is
his second start of the season ninth
appearance since being traded from the
brewers back on may 21st and aj kevin
cash told us this is no doubt a bullpen
day for this raised ball club one two
pitch on its way here's a check swing he
went around alaska third he did go and
they'll tag him just to make sure and
that'll do it for the indians in the
first
joey wendell lead things off
this one on the ground
and food at bradley tries to recover but
safe at first mike cenino a 198 batting
average a swing and a miss went with a
slider away and he struck out zanino so
mejia gets his third strikeout
one-nothing raise middle of the second
and here's bobby bradley well you talk
about a guy that is struggling
bobby bradley does not have a base hit
in his last 13 advance the 1-1
swung on hit a ton deep left field this
one has got a chance go on to the
bleachers that's how you break it over
13 skid
an opposite field home run to left for
bobby bradley is the 11th
and we've got a tie ball game and one
phillips will starter than the top of
the order against the tall right-hander
mejia
here's a high drive into d brain field
johnson moving back to the warning track
back to the wall
gone home run
brent phillips with his career high
fifth home run and the rays take a 2-1
lead hey they're not going to have the
shutdown inning that you were just
talking about rays who have a 2-1 lead
have choi at second
and that'll take something with two outs
from austin meadows
[Applause]
this ball hit well to right
hugging the line
and it is fair and it is gone
the balls are flying out of the park
tonight at progressive field
a two-run jack by austin meadows and
it's now four to one
[Applause]
grass plus one two fastball struggle to
miss strike three sometimes guys just
are never gonna catch up to high heat at
98. he tried one breaking ball in the
sequence and said let's just go fastball
against this guy and he got him one out
impressive thing about rasmussen is
he's 33 pitches in still throwing 98 99
mile an hour heaters at these guys
and 99 right there
blowing it by bradley zimmer quickly two
out in the bottom of the third
takes over for drew rasmussen
pretty darn good in his three innings to
open this game three innings one hit one
runner was a home run hit by bobby
bradley did not walk about or struck out
three here's jose ramirez switcher to
heading left
and down looking as ramirez he did not
like the call from tony randazzo it's
been a generous strike so we've talked
about a few times with tony randazzo
this ball
ramirez thinks he's high
never really breaks stays at the top and
let's see how many pitches he can steal
away
[Applause]
into the glove
on the shift of lau as he snags it out
of the air and we've got four in the
books in cleveland
and now the indians will send ramirez
johnson and hedges to the plate
and there he chases the breaker away and
ramirez goes down on strikes so
lewis head has already fanned three and
he's only face five
this one
95 miles per hour down the line phillips
right on the chalk has to back pedal but
he does make the play to retire daniel
johnson and the one-two pitch is swung
on and missed strike three hedges is
down on strikes and it's a one two three
inning
for lewis head he's retired the last six
men that he has faced
and out to left center field pretty well
hit drifting back up against the wall
zimmer able to hang on to it
that just kept going and going off the
bat of franco but zimmer able
he catches it he hits the wall you'll
see it's not in his glove
it comes out
is that challengeable yep
he's fighting for this guy
but
did it hit the wall at any point if it
did it'd be a
hit then if it does if they rule that i
want to see where they place the runners
and they will say out so
wander franco is retired he's over three
the pitch swing and a little floater
into shallow right center and a leaping
grab with us back to home by cesar
hernandez
he ranged a long way into right center
and caught that little looping liner
with his back to home played on a leap
the right-hander's ready
here it comes
swinging a little tamper out toward the
mound near the plate coming to get it
high throw by the pitcher head off
choice club cams off the sidewall on the
first base side and foul territory to
third to zimmer hernandez to second
jose ramirez batting left-handed grounds
and sharply to first fielded by joy
he'll go to the bag himself to get
ramirez scoring his zimmer hernandez to
third how does this guy have a job
that's three unassisted if you're
scoring with us it's not a fielder's
choice
next up we'll do the abc's
it's a four to two game
and with one out one on upstops jimon
choi who was involved in everything
defensively last inning one ball no
strikes and the pitch lifted the air
towards left tough play towards the
corner ramirez to his right can't get it
takes a bounce and high off the wall and
karim's far away phillips around third
and he will score troy into second with
his third extra base hit of the night
and they're all going to the opposite
field the rays lead five to two so two
men down runner at third
and that'll leave it for ahmed rosario
senino with a sign springs from the full
lined up he pitches swinging a mess he
struck him out on a ball of the dirt and
zanino throws to first to finish him off
and the indians are turned away here in
the eighth inning as that potential
third run stranded
loud moves in the scoring position not a
chance at all for bobby bradley and so
now a base hit should be able to get the
raise their sixth run here's g-man choi
and g-man with a three-hit knight
ground ball and this time to the right
side a four-hit knight and then an air
by mercado so lau will score easily
and tampa gets an insurance run it's now
six to two here's austin meadows
this is hit pretty well to right center
drifting back track wall two-minute leap
but it's gone
austin meadows
does it again his second two-run homer
of the night and the rays have opened
this up at the top of the night well the
indians are down
to their final out the 1-1 swing and a
line drive caught by wendell at third
and that's your ball game and the rays
are now in a tie for first place in the
american league east